so this we uh
love it and the speaker just confirmed
that he agrees
that it's great if we have a lot of
interactivity during this seminar so
please don't be shy please don't
save your questions for the bitter end
let us know
about any questions concern comments
right away
please um you can ask questions
in the chat i mean there okay there are
several ways there's the q a you can
totally use it
for some reason we usually don't there
is the chat
that is people tend to use that a lot if
you do please make sure
to send your messages to all panelists
and attendees you get this this scroll
down menu
with options all panelists and attend
panelists and attend this is
what what will reach everybody uh
you can also speak but i think only if
you're a panelist
some some seminar attendees are more
equal than others they are known as
panelists
and then there are attendees and they
can only listen
however if you are an attendee
that wishes to receive an upgrade now is
the time to speak
or send me a message or whatever and
will be super happy to upgrade you
i usually don't do upgrades during the
seminar because you will lose
connectivity for a while before you
reconnect
but like any one of the attendees who
would like to become a panelist now just
say the word and we'll be totally happy
to do it
is there anything else i'm supposed to
do and i put all of this in the chat
already
anything else i should say so this is a
simon's workshop seminar
and all everybody who are registered
for the workshop which most people
should be if they're attending this
meeting
are welcome together at gather town
after the seminar and i put that link in
the chat also
in a best case scenario i will remember
to repeat it towards the end of the
seminar
we will have kind of a two-part seminar
this tuesday as we usually do
a 40-50-ish
minute first part on quantified boolean
formulas oval
solving qbf solving and then after a
break
10 minute break maybe a slightly shorter
part on going into things like more like
i think first order logic
and satisfiability modulo theories smt
but the speaker will
make everything clear in just a minute
as soon as i let him start
which i'm about to do now i guess
unless there's something else
which i don't think and i think the
participant number has now
jumped in the customary way and
stabilized
um so why don't we get going
so it's an immense pleasure today to
have with us mikolaj
yanota uh at the uh
czech technical university in prague
and again we won't waste time on
extolling mikolaj's cv
we just want to hear him talk about his
exciting research again which has
been i think it's fair to say focused on
automated reasoning in different forms
and shapes in particular
mikolaj has done a lot of exciting work
on
qbf solving and i think he will tell us
about some of it today
and how to harness the power of machine
learning in
this space but all of this is really
speculation
nicholas will tell us now please
okay so hello everyone so um there's
these
sections so a little bit of intro on qbf
some of it you might have heard from
already from martina
seidel so there might be a little bit of
overlap but i think
this should this should this is kind of
necessary to
make the the talk complete
and then i will say on a little bit on
my work on
solving qbf and how you can use machine
learning within
qbf and then
in the second part is about how some of
these techniques can be lifted to first
order logic
and one context is the finite models
right so meaning that if you have a
first order logic formula
you want to find a finite model if there
is one there might not be one
and there you can also try to do machine
learning
and the last part is about what
i've been doing most recently which is
about applying machine learning in the
context of satisfiability modular
theories
um also just to give a little bit of
just just contextually where i am now
so i've been living in portugal for
many years and now i moved back to
prague and
i started a research group here at the
technical university of prague
and the focus is exactly this the the
satisfactory modular theories
so um so i'm happy to to show uh some of
the works that we've been doing it's a
little bit recent because i
moved just a couple of months ago
essentially
um but i i hope it's it's interesting
okay um so yeah let's let's get going
so um you all know that in sat we are
just asking
if a formula is satisfiable or not and
if it is then we would like to have an
assignment for the variables that makes
it as
satisfiable in qbf
i still have the same language but i can
also write quantifiers
and since it's finite i can rewrite the
quantifiers into
boolean connectives so for all is just a
conjunction
and axis is a disjunction so if i take a
formula
i can completely get rid of the
quantified part
by rewriting it into these boolean
connectives
so for instance in this step here i took
the exist y
and i rewrote this in a disjunction
of course it was at the price that the
size of the formula doubled
right so i need to say either it's true
for zero or it's true for one
and i can do the same for the or
sorry the four all by saying a
conjunction
so it must be true if x
is 1 or x is false
and this actually after i did they've
done
done all this well then i can just get
rid of
all the connectives i can simplify to a
single constant
so it's a it's obviously decidable but
if i do it
like this the whole formula grows too
much
and this is something we would like to
avoid in this in
in practical solving
um oh yeah as as jakob said you can stop
me
at any time i'm kind of going through
this uh
slightly more accelerated because i'm
i'm
sure that most of you have seen it but
if someone some of you
haven't just stopped me um then there is
um also this relation between qbf
and first order logic so sometimes i
present my work
to some people that work with first
order logic and
they think i'm talking greek to them or
chinese
and so i i'd like to have this slide
that shows that the step
going from qbf to first star logic is
not
that huge so if for instance i have this
formula that says
that for all you exist e
you if and only if e right so these are
just boolean variables that can only be
zero and one
and this formula of course is true
because if i set
u to one then say i set e also to one
and the other way around and i can
rewrite this to first r logic by adding
a special predicate that represents uh
through truth so i'm kind of reifying
truth and i have two constants one
one represents the truth and the other
represents
falsity and i say that truth should
always be true and falsity should always
not be true right so i have these two
constants
and then if i want to rewrite this
original formula
i just say well for whatever value uh u
has um if u is true
then the predicate over u must be true
so i replaced the sorry the existential
variable
with the predicate so for every
existential variable in the original
formula
i introduced a predicate and
for uh for every universal variable i
just kind of
wrap it in this truth reification
um anyhow i don't want to go in too much
detail
um it's those that are familiar with
first our logic so they might recognize
that this is the verniz
shin finkel fragment or sometimes people
say epr
which means that i don't have functions
i have only constants and predicates
which also means that the urban universe
is
finite so okay so so
so the details might not be completely
crucial if you don't understand them
right now
but something to take take home is that
you can go from qbf to first start logic
so you can translate
qbf into first order logic rather in a
rather straightforward fashion
what is little bit strange is that the
original formula was
symmetric right so there is no
particular difference between the
quantifiers in the qbf case
but in the first order case somehow all
of a sudden
they are treated differently this is
something that
i've that's been puzzling me for for a
long time i don't think there's any good
answer to that and another
annoying thing is that the epr fragment
is decidable so it's a decidable
fragment
of first start logic but the complexity
of
this fragment is different than qbf so
qbf is p
space and bernice schinfinkel is a next
type
next time complete okay so so this uh
this this one nice relation between qbf
and first star logic um
then of course we can ask yeah
i guess you already told us that we
shouldn't worry too much
but let me just quickly worry and then
you'll tell me
that i should maybe but if you go back
so like
is there any reason for me to think
about what a how how would a
like a disjunctive clause be translated
that mixes universal and existential
variables or we should just move on and
ignore this
oh no this is yeah this is this is a
this i think that should be easy
uh to um answer right so
i'm not even assuming conjunctive normal
form
i mean i'm just you know so um
so this is even i could right so
here i have i this is actually this can
be thought of as two clauses right but i
i have if and only if so i'm not
assuming cnf and then
so each of the literals that you uh
sorry
that you have in the propositional case
you replace it with a literal so it's a
mapping between literals to literals
all right and and the the universal ones
they're um wrapped in this in this
truth thing so so because
i because the the existential variables
they stop
being variables they become predicates
and the universal variables are still
variables but they need to be
wrapped in this truth because i cannot
use a variable
as a term but i could think of this as
like a liter a literal biliteral
syntactic replacement yeah it's a
completely formula will be exactly the
same
yeah you got it yeah yeah so there's the
question so the transformation qbf is
strictly included in epr
yes yes well i mean of course
uh the language is different right but
the step
of of moving from qbf to a subset of epr
is um is fairly easy yeah
uh then there's the question isn't
p e like a scotland function
yeah yeah this is this is the same idea
yeah so this
uh this p e behaves like a like a skull
and function
um it's it's essentially the same idea
there's something about ibner universal
oh
sorry inner variables i was afraid that
you're asking about ibner variables and
i didn't know what they were
um so you're asking about
inner universal variables um
i don't think there is an issue
so i mean the the univ the the
quantifier prefix is the same
you just remove well oh okay so
maybe if you're familiar with
colonization as as was said
here right so it's kind of the same
process right so
the in the end i have only universal
quantifiers and the existentials
they're just predicates that have
in their arguments
the predicates that are before the
original existential
um yeah i'm
yeah well anyhow i mean uh
this is more more of a of a side remark
that um that
so this so this is this is not so much
uh the target of the talk but
um it's it's it's a it's a nice relation
so
um so uh okay so uh let me
move on so uh just a little bit of
background so smt
i'm sure that most of you have heard of
smt
and i'm not going into any technical
details about
smt uh we're just assuming that
there are some theories like natural
numbers or reals
or uh functions that we can
reason about so besides
the standard first order logic semantics
we also have
the semantics of the theory that is
being considered
so for instance in this example i'm
saying that i have a function
and i don't i don't know what the
function is it's it is a
it is a function and we call such
functions uninterpreted functions
because we don't know
what their interpretation is we have to
find it if there is one
and i'm saying that for whatever
x which is a natural number f x has to
give a positive value
and additionally i say that if
um that f of 0 is negative right so this
is a contradictory formula
because if it's supposed to um
if f supposed to be positive everywhere
but supposed to be negative on zero
that's a that's a contradiction so
this is not particularly difficult to
see
um of course i can have more complex
examples so for instance
i have i'm saying that f is
increasing right so i'm going uh if i go
from
fx to fx plus one i have to go up
and then i'm saying that i decrease
every hundred steps
right so it's a those are kind of a
strange property right so it's
increasing
every step and then decreasing every 100
steps
and if you think about it that's also
contradictory but
it's not not so obvious obviously i have
to know
that the comparison so less than and
greater than
they um they are transitive
and i have to know something about plus
and etc
so this is uh this is um
this is uh oh yes sir philippe is saying
they're
saying it's esker stairs yeah it's true
it's exactly
exactly exactly that that's a good name
for this formula
um so um also i mean
as a fun exercise is is uh to think
about if you replace
here 100 with a positive constant right
so if you say
this is it's decreasing every
every c steps and and c is is a
is some positive constant i i don't know
which one
and uh if that's the case that i think
you need induction to prove this and
this is typically
out of out of reach for nowadays solvers
i know i'm not gonna talk at all about
the induction but um
just to you know just to um show
uh what are some of the peculiarities
that might
that might appear
okay so
we have qbf and a relation to first our
logic
we have smd which is kind of an
extension of first start logic to
specific theories and
there is also this nice relation that i
really like to use
that between qbf and two-player games
so what we imagine is that we have two
players the for
all player and the existential player
and the for all player
is is trying to make the formula false
and the existential is trying to make
the formula
true and they're giving
values to the variables according to the
quantifier prefix right so they're
alternating based on what is written in
the quantifier prefix and they
either give 0 or 1 to each of the
variables
and a qbf is false if and only if there
exists a winning strategy for the
universal player and it's true if and
only if there exists a winning strategy
for the existential player
which also means that we don't have
stalemates
so there is always a winning strategy
for for one of the players
either of the players so for instance
this formula
is true because
well um one point of view is that i just
expand
right so i plug in these boolean
connectives and that was a lot of work
because we had to expand everything
or i can think about the game and the
game is what
the existentiality is waiting for what
the universal is going to play and it's
going to play exactly the same value
and it's always going to win because
they just need to be equal
right so this is this is a kind of a
nice example
how it's useful to think about these
quantifiers as two-player games because
i can reason very quickly
why this formula is true
okay so this is this is
a bit of background so there's
a lot of work on solving qbf and i'm
going to mainly talk about
what i've been doing you've heard by
from martina
about the other approaches i'm sure
so one observation is that we can
write the universal quantifier
as a conjunct uh con conjunction
conjunctive
conjunct l conjunction well
um so if i have
universal variables here in the inner
inner quantifier so i'm saying
x's some existential variables for all
some universal variables and some
formula phi
i can get rid of the universals by
writing a conjunction
by going over all the combinations of
the inner quantifier
the inner variables and
now i don't have qbf anymore because i
have just one quantifier
which is called sat right so if i have
x's and bunch of variables and no more
quantifiers
this is exactly the same as solving sat
so this is good news because i don't
need a qbf solver i can just run a sat
solver and sat solvers are very good
the issue here is that the expansion is
too big
right so maybe such solvers are very
good but it might
happen that i'm not even able to
construct the expansion
because i need to consider all the
values for the inner variables
and there might be just too many
so there is this nice idea that instead
of
expanding all the values so all the bit
vectors
that that might give value to the inner
variables here
i will try just some and that
sometimes um sometimes helps right so
um well i don't know maybe maybe i could
try some
audience participation uh so i have this
qbf formula
and i'm claiming that
i don't need to consider all values for
the inner quantifier
but i only need two two possibilities
of the three three variables
anyone has a suggestion
or maybe i can ask a simpler question so
if we think about the two player game
right so
i claim this formula is false meaning
that
whatever value is given to x
the universal quantifier can respond
with something that
falsifies the formula so let's say
x is false what should the universal
player
play to to make it false
play all them true yeah
then w yeah so if if the x
is set to false the universal player
just sets everything
to true here and that will
force falsity and this
falsifies everything because there's a
conjunction here
and obviously here it's symmetric i just
need to play
all false if x is true
yeah so this means that the universal
player really needed
only two types of moves either play
everything true or play everything false
depending what the value of x is
so if i plug in these two values instead
of these
two to the power of three possible
values if i plug only these two
i will get one implies x and
one implies not x which which really
simplifies to false
now the tricky part is what is a good
expansion right so
what are the what are the good
moves of the inner quantifier that
the that we should consider
and there's this nice idea that we can
do this gradually using this counter
example guided abstraction refinement
which which sounds very fancy but
it's really just this idea that we try
to play something
and the opponent beats us with a counter
move
and we prepare ourselves for the
opponent
sorry we prepare ourselves not to be
beaten again by the same counter move
right so we're kind of collecting the
counter moves
that we have been beaten with
until we find a move that cannot be
beaten
or we just know that there is no uh
there is no move for the outer
quantifier
yeah so what is uh roughly what is going
on i pick
a value for the other quantifier all
right so
i'm still talking about these uh this
case where i just have two
levels of quantifiers but this can be
generalized
so i pick the first value
and i check by running a sub solver if
this can be falsified
meaning that the universal player can
win
if that's the case we have a counter
move
and we need to prepare ourselves for
this counter move so we don't want to be
beaten ever again by
by this counter move meaning that we
should be
able to satisfy the formula if the
opponent played this counter move that
just beaten us
yeah and this gives us a new candidate
move
and again we check if this can be beaten
and
if yes we get a counter move
and we plug it in and we're saying well
you have to
be able to win if either of those
counter moves is played in the second
round yeah and we repeat our
repeat this process until either
we find a move that cannot be beaten
or this conjunction becomes
unsatisfiable
yeah and if you think about this what is
happening
is that we're gradually expanding
this conjunction so originally we said
the universal quantifier can be
rewritten as a
huge conjunction
but rather than doing that we're just
doing it one by one
any questions here so far
how would i know i mean n is uh
potentially exponential here
so of course i might get start start to
worry that
you know i'm not making much progress
but i would yeah
usually n doesn't grow too large or
there's a good way of figuring out
whether we're making progress
yeah so that that's a good question so i
guess the short
answer is that as long as the polynomial
hierarchy
doesn't collapse um
we don't we don't have too much hope
that
that we can uh bound this n
right because if n is small then i have
a small number of sate calls um
for um for a problem in the second level
of polynomial hierarchy
so theoretically speaking right it's
it's unlikely that we will ever have
algorithms that will be able to
somehow bound this number of sat calls
um no no that's clear but even
even for for we're aiming to solve
formulas that are easy in some sense
right yeah sure sure
even for easy formulas this could be
like a terrible approach or it could be
genius or somewhere yeah yeah yeah yeah
it could be both so
actually this is this is what i'm gonna
talk about next so
um so yes so yeah let me let me
let me get to that um just uh uh
just a quick um quick recap
what is nice about this algorithm you
can write this really
uh fairly easily in um
we're just using two set calls a to a
in in each loop right so this is not uh
not very difficult to implement so if
you have only two quantifier levels
uh you have to worry a little bit about
the fact that
you're manipulating these formulas which
might potentially not be
cnf and um so
you need the formula and the disjunction
sorry under negation
um so you need to you know introduce
satan variables if you're using
uh um as a cnf
sat solvers in the end
um but again again so it's this is not
not particularly hard to uh to to
implement
um just a side remark the original
argument
algorithm is is non-cnf right so
this this has some some advantages
because cnf is known to bring in
some problems for qbf
and it can also be generalized to
arbitrary number of levels and this is
essentially done by
recursion so this algorithm is doing
exactly the same
but instead of calling sat solver again
it calls itself in
in the in the lower levels uh
and it can also be generalized to to um
non-cnf sorry not not pre-ex
anyhow okay so um
let me get to uh to what the jacob was
asking about
so what are the good and the bad and the
ugly cases of
of this algorithm so
what is nice is that it can stop early
so imagine this situation that we have
axis
and bunch of variables for all y
and some other variables they don't
matter and some formula that says that
phi and y should be true at the same
time
and we don't know what the what phi is
but it doesn't matter because
as long as i set y to false
everything is false right so it doesn't
matter
what what's the rest but i can
win this very easily by just saying y is
false
yeah so this this is the nice case when
we just plug in a value
and everything everything stops right
away
you can do something similar for for
truth
right so if if i have something like x
or phi and again if x is true then the
whole thing is true and it doesn't
matter what the rest is
and uh so so again this is something
that stops right away
now what is happening is when
uh what is well what is
bad and i will i will get to this
in more detail but essentially the idea
is that if
for every candidate move i have a
different
counter move right so i'm just kind of
i'm essentially not learning from the
previous
counter moves because i need always
a different uh different counter move
so this is kind of a vague vague
description of the problem
so imagine you have something like this
so you're saying exist
x such that for all y they're equal
well this is not true right because
again from the perspective of the
game if x is true y is false
if x is false y is uh y is true
right so they just play the opposite and
the universal always wins by falsifying
the equality here
however if i do the expansion i really
need
these two values so this is
this doesn't look very good right
because it's a very simple formula and i
really need to see that y can be true
and false all right so i need two
iterations for for this formula
and as you know things grow
exponentially very
easily i can just make it ugly by
putting a disjunction between a bunch of
formulas of the same type they are
completely independent
and maybe i could detect that with some
pre-processing but of course that's
that's beyond the point
what is happening is that i'm saying
well find me a vector of variables x 1 x
2
such that for any vector of the y
variables at least one of these
equalities
is true and
the response is well it's not possible
because again
the universal plays exactly the opposite
right so where it mirrors the
uh it plays the negation of of this and
it
falsifies all the disjunctions
okay so we need all these all these four
values of
y one and y two
because i there you have been a question
in the chat for a while oh yeah
this is something that okay so this is
something that we were looking at
also this has been uh very annoying
um well not very annoying but it's
it's something that is counter intuitive
so there is no good way of
um using partial assignments
[Music]
without going into much detail at least
i haven't figured
figured out really how how that would
work
so so you're plugging
essentially you're alternating the two
players so
like if i if i go into this more
intuitive
notion of two player games and if i
plug in only a partial move of one of
the players i'm just making it easier
for the other one rather than making it
more difficult
yeah so i mean um i don't know if that's
you know it's a good if it's a
sufficient answer but um
it i've never figured out a good way how
how partial moves would would be um
helpful
at the beginning i also thought there
might be a way of of
of um of doing that but
um yeah
um yeah okay so
so this brings me to this part which is
about machine learning
in qbf and it's motivated
by exactly this problem
that i have a bit vector so i'm looking
for a bit vector that certainly doesn't
exist we already know that but the
solver doesn't
so i'm looking for a bit vectors or a
sequence of boolean variables
so that for any other bit vector at
least
one of the bits is the same
yeah so i'm saying find a bit vector so
that for any other bit vector
at least one of the bits is the same and
we know that this is not possible
but it this problem has this annoying
property that
for whatever bit vector i consider for
the first part
there is one that makes all these
disjunctions false
and it's exactly one so it's the one
that plays the opposite right so i flip
all the values of of the variables and
none of the disjunctions is is satisfied
uh but it's exactly one that is that is
uh violating it
and so there is this
sort of a um
i'm i'm i probably wouldn't say paradox
but something that's been
i think nagging the the qbf community is
that i have a formula that is fairly
easy to see why it's false meaning
that there is a small strategy for
the universal player or for either of
the players doesn't matter
but if i run the solver it's going to
need
a lot of time so in particular it will
just expand
all the possibilities so this is exactly
the case
which jakob was pointing out
in the worst case i'm expanding
exponentially many times
and here i'm doing exactly exponentially
many times i'm doing exactly the
the full number of expansions
but it's strange because
there is a easy response right so
if if i know that the universal player
plays the opposite i can just plug in
this value
and everything falsifies right it
simplifies to false
so if i plug in instead of zeros and
ones if i plug in the negation
of the x's everything becomes false
but where do i get these functions so
rather than you know rather than
plugging in constants i want to plug in
functions in
in this case it's a negation of the
particular variable
but where do i get them right so this is
this is um the hard question
and what i did i was i tried to use
machine learning
for exactly this and it's a little bit
different approach of machine learning
than what we're
usually used to so typically we use
machine learning
to give some sort of guidance or
classification
but here we really need the object so
we're trying to learn
an object that will represent the
function
so we're still playing this game of
candidates and counter moves so we
just go back and forth and the idea
is to observe some sort of a pattern
in the counter moves
and we observe this pattern by
running machine learning for each of the
individual variables
and then if we have the pattern
or we we hope that we have the right
pattern
we plug it into the formula instead of
these constants
0 and 1. so this is
roughly the the idea and we can repeat
and just to just to show uh on this
example so
so this this would be the sequence of
games that i'm playing so i have these
you know two move games so i
played zero zero zero zero and the
response was 1 1 1 1
1. so it's always playing the negation
and then i see well 0 0 0 didn't work
so i will flip the first bit and
the opponent also flips the first bit
and again wins and i repeat and repeat
and repeat
and eventually if i run
some machine learning algorithm it will
figure out
that the response for the universal
is the negation of the existential
right and
we repeat this and we plug that in and
and it really works
now um what is what is how it is exactly
done
well not exactly but it's roughly done
in in the in the
implementation so i i do the loop as you
have seen before
i still do recursion to have multiple
levels
i still do the refinement meaning i plug
in the values
and functions and i
don't run learning all the time i just
run it ever
every k steps and the k is
maybe like 32 or 16 i tried different
different versions it's not too much so
it's a it's a little bit of
a typical learning because in in typical
machine learning
you have many data points here i have
just a few data points
and now what i'm using to learn
is decision trees and why do i use
decision trees
because they give me an object that i
can pick up
and plug into the formula back again and
so
if i used a neural network it wouldn't
be any use to me because
i cannot take a neural network and write
it into the qbf
or maybe i could with a lot of effort
but it would make the qbf
harder harder to solve than it was
before
aside remark there is this additional
heuristic that i
really needed was that if i learned
already some function in the previous
iterations
i kept it as long as it was working so i
i kept i called this don't fix what i
broke so
you know if you learn something and it's
working
don't try to relearn
any questions here
um just a little bit of results so this
is already
you know 2018 but
so at the time i was very excited
because i tried a bunch of different
things in qbf
and this was really the first time i was
getting
getting some improvement it's maybe
maybe
questions this is like is this uh
specific to you i guess you did two two
qbfs so far
oh yeah so so i do this um
i do this more like a generic uh it's
just so it's
it works for multiple levels by
recursion
uh-huh okay yeah so i didn't want to
really get into the
recursive part it's it gets a little bit
more technical but
it the whole algorithm is implemented
for
for arbitrary number of levels having
said that
these algorithms don't seem to work very
well for
many levels so you know if you have
three levels i think it's fine
if if more then maybe a different solver
might be better but but it could happen
when you say don't fix what ain't broke
it could be that your your strategy
function like
keeps coming up with good counter moves
to the
i guess for all unsat player and then
you'll just let this function play for a
while
well i i it's it's a little bit tricky
because you have these multiple
variables and you have
a separate function for each variable
so i'm you know so there so there
the strategies are changing it's just
those that are
that seem to work i'm i'm keeping them
right so
i mean if i go back to this example for
instance
um you know if i look at the the first
two
samples here
i see that y n the last
variable is always true so any
reasonable machine learning algorithm
just says well then display always true
right so don't
don't invent anything i mean if it's
always true just play always true
right but then you know
in the next step i already see oh it's
it's it's false here
um so i need to reflect that
so there are a number of questions in
the in the chat now that are
accumulating that we should
read out because they won't be visible
in in the video recording posted on
youtube but if you could read them and
answer them yeah
what happens if the function you learn
is wrong
meaning that once you see more of the
truth assignments the learn function
is invalidated yeah so the so the
good answer is there's no wrong answers
so there's no wrong uh wrong functions
and what does it mean so
this boils down basically to this idea
that it's a universal quantifier
right so if i have a formula
that says well exist
where is some formula if i have a
formula x is for all
an arbitrary formula and not not
necessarily this one
but if i have an axis for all formula
uh something like this
dx the existential value
has to work for whatever the u variable
happens to be
right so whatever the function is
for you the the e has to be right
yeah so so um
i mean from complexity point of view
uh and i i mean i probably should make
this remark is
there is something a little bit strange
right because
so i can i can solve this by plugging in
all possible constant vectors of u
so this will grow exponentially so i can
i can convert to sat
by by by converting to an exponentially
large formula
but if i'm trying functions all of a
sudden
the space is double exponential right
because the number of functions is much
larger
so this is so so so this is a little bit
strange
however it's still the case that
whatever whatever
strategy the the second second player is
is doing it must it must work right so
the
the first player must play something
that beats any possible strategy
hopefully that answers the question oh
there's one more question what
guarantees that these learned functions
are simple smaller
well nothing we're just hoping that you
know we're just hoping that
that the learning algorithm will learn
a small tree in my case it's a decision
tree
and this is kind of the aim of machine
learning right to have
small explanations but of course there's
no guarantee
there could be easily some threshold so
i could decide
not to use the learn function if it's if
it looks too complicated but
i haven't done that that would be easy
to do
uh then there is a question this is
really synthesis of herb brand functions
counterparts of cons function isn't it
yes yes this is uh this is a synthesis
of
herb brand functions or scolam functions
depending on the quantifier so
this is completely symmetric with
respect to quantifiers
so you can either see it as synthesis of
scolum or
or air brand functions it doesn't really
matter in qbf
okay let me go let me
go yeah so i think
um there's been uh there's been some
good questions
um now i have the second part on finite
models and maybe it's the it's a good
time to
to do a break i'm not sure what time it
is
exactly is it too soon no this is an
excellent time it's it's 25 minutes past
the hour
so i guess let's let's just say that if
there are any
other oh yeah sure questions we can we
can take them now and
and uh as soon as we're done with any
outstanding questions uh we'll take uh
a ten minute break uh are there any
questions from anyone
yeah come on um very nice talk
could you please um say a little bit
more about the problems with the cnf
uh in qbf i think you you only
you don't only refer to the site and
transform because then you don't know
which variable
a new variable would be on which exit
existential level and
and what are all the problems could you
say a little oh yeah
um yeah i don't have any slides on that
um
but essentially the the
okay so the the maybe there's different
responses to that so one thing is the
level you're right
so i have to decide at which level i'm
going to put the existential variables
and of course you can always put them
all the way to the end
which is to which might not be a good
idea so we actually have some small
paper uh with all of bayer starve
and
that that that shows that if you move
them
all the way to the end it might be much
worse than
bringing uh bringing them more
uh more to the left if you can right so
they always have to appear to the right
of the variables
that they are kind of uh represent
um anyhow so yeah this is just one
one thing but uh roughly speaking
i think the intuition here is that if
you give
the solver the satan variables
the solver doesn't know that they are
satan variables
so when you construct the satan variable
you know exactly what the interpretation
should be right so let's say you have
that satan variable that represents a
conjunction
so you know what's the strategy for that
variable
play the conjunction of the two literals
that
that are represented by that satan
variable
but the solver doesn't know that right
so
it has to somehow figure figure it out
on its own and um
it might not it might not be able to you
know it might be just
a lot of work to actually do that so i
mean of course you could try to do it
syntactically
so you can go and oh actually this was
probably a satan variable so maybe i
should you know
but then so why did why did someone
make it into cnf if someone has to go
and
and go back right so i mean this is a
bit of ungrateful
um line of work to uh to reverse
engineering
uh reverse engineering or near the the
encoding
one another another
issue that is very visible in
in the uh in the algorithm here
so you need the formula
and it's negation right so you need both
uh
f and the negation of f now
if you have a formula and
so if you start with a non-cnn formula
bring it into cnf via satan
transformation
as it is equi-satisfiable
which doesn't mean it's equivalent right
so if you give me
an equisatifiable formula using the
satan transformation and i go
and i negate that
no longer it holds that double negation
cancels
itself out right yeah i mean if you can
if you think about it right so imagine
you you take a non-cnf
you bring it into cnf by by satan
and somebody gives that to you and you
negate well how do you negate you bring
bring in a new set of satan variables to
negate
the cnf and in fact you should be able
to get the same formula because you
negate it twice
but it's not the case yeah i hopefully
that
that clarifies the um
to a degree you get some yeah there
there is
there's two papers there's actually an
older paper
um one is called um
achilles heel off and i forgot of what
so and i have another paper which is
called achilles heel of
term resolution um and
they both talk about this issue of cnf
um version
okay thank you
there's one more question oh yeah the
synthesis
yeah that that that would probably be
interesting this the synthesis compared
to uh
synthesis i think it depends a lot on
the benchmark so my
impression is that it will probably not
work so well because the the qbf
problems are
typically rather large so you have
number a large number of variables and
the formula is large
it's a bit of a also a chicken and egg
problem so i know that
there's been work on using qbf
within synthesis right so uh
marcus rabe has worked on this um
so i i feel like there might be some
sort of a
chicken and egg problem yeah but i
it it would probably make sense to um
uh to look at this i mean um
there is related to this is that
in smt um andrew reynolds
has work um within cvc4 so cbc4
is an smt solver and he's using
the smt solver to synthesize
things and it's it's kind of based on
on some similar ideas that i've been
using in qbf
um so he i think he calls it
uh synthesis by refutation or um
something like this um again so it's
it's uh there is um and so
he's been he's been doing a lot of work
on this um
so so there is definitely this this
relation
and on top of that a bit of a chicken
and egg problem that
it feels like you could use the solvers
to do synthesis and maybe you could use
synthesis to
to improve the solvers um yeah there's
problem
there's there's definitely more work to
be done here
okay thanks so let's take a 10 minute
break
starting now and then we'll be back to
talk about
uh finite model theory right yeah
perfect
so i think that we are
preparing to resume in uh about a minute
or so
if people have had time to grab their
coffee
or you know morning coffee
coffee evening coffee midnight
coffee early morning coffee depending on
where on the globe you are
i try to avoid drinking coffee at this
time of the day
yeah yeah yeah but we should ask
supratik about that
yeah i'm happy to have tea i'm in the
same time zone as
not coffee but day is fine okay
even this time of day yeah anytime i
i'll have it at midnight also
it's not midnight here
it would have what is this calling like
rowibus or something i could do that but
nothing more nothing stronger than that
red bush yeah yes
okay so let's see have we um
what should we do have a tea discussion
coffee discussion or should we
perhaps i mean one suggestion could be
to let the
mikolaj continue
i could quickly organize a poll on this
or maybe i'll just
stop blathering and say that we're back
from the break and mikolaj
it's uh all yours again please okay
so um so okay so this kind of closes the
the chapter on um qbf
and now um i'm kind of getting more into
this
kind of more exploratory stuff
so one thing that i tried
was using or applying the same ideas
in the context of finite model finding
and why should this work
well we can imagine this finite model
finding as a kind of a higher order
quantifier
right so instead of looking for some
boolean variables
we are asking are there predicates and
functions that will
satisfy our formula for whatever
the value of the universal
variables are in that formula
and if it's if it's finite then
maybe it's not so far from qbf because
the the predicates can still be written
um finitely right so they're they're
large they're much larger
because um the if i want to write
like a truth table or or for a function
i need like a multiplication table
they're much larger but they're still
finite if i'm just looking for
finite models so i can try the same
trick
so first i don't assume anything
and then i find some interpretation for
this
for this empty assumption so i find an
arbitrary assumption
sorry interpretation uh
if there is no interpretation i stop
in this case in the first round this is
impossible
and then i test if the interpretation
that i just
got whether it's a good one right so i
have a i have some interpretation for my
practice
and for my functions that are unknown
and
i check if it's a good one if not
i have some value for the universal
quantified variables
that negates the model right so the
interpretation well
the interpretation is not a model
of the formula and we say
well you have a counter example we have
to be able to
find an interpretation for the
predicates
and the functions so that it is able to
deal with this particular value of the
universal variables
so again it's this same idea it's this
it's just that the do two players a
little bit asymmetric
so i still have existential and
universal
but the existential is playing over
predicates and functions
and the universal is playing over the
the first order variables
very very stupid question what is alpha
here and like
oh yeah this is just like this is like
my approximation of the formula
so um if it's it's getting gradually
strengthened
all right so if uh so this is this is
still
the same story right because i'm in
finite domain if because i'm
interested in finite models if i plug
all possible values for x's
alpha will be just a um a conjunction
over uh over all these combinations
yeah and and i'm looking for
and then it's it's um it's essentially
an epr
apr problem right because once you
uh once you got rid of the first order
logic variables you only have predicates
and functions
and constants i guess what i'm not
seeing is
are you setting them somewhere at the
outset is that like
so i guess i'm missing something but is
this part of yeah it's it's
yeah it's this is sorry so i'm i just
kind of
um you know i i just kind of wanted to
um
um to keep this um short
um and a little bit informal but yes the
it's this is this is on the way this is
written is unclear yes so you're right
so
i'm i'm gradually strengthening the
problem so again i'm
you know i have a fixed value for the
for the first order logic variables i
plug them in
sure and i and i add that to to alpha
okay so alpha is is just growing
and and then i
capital i or fancy style i i should
think
of uh interpretation
okay it's an interpretation so
you know so so alpha is like an epr
problem essentially it's like it does
well
it's not well it's in finite
it's a finite model problem where i
don't have
any variables um any
any four started logic variables all
right so
i is like what you'll be playing for for
the ps and the f's
exactly yeah exactly yeah okay yeah
exactly yeah yeah so this i is what
you're playing for the
uh for the interpretation for the first
player
and then in line four the for all player
gets a new chance
yeah yeah yeah okay
okay got it thanks yeah i was just
confused sorry yeah no i
i yeah this um yeah i i g i i just you
know
this this is still still the same idea
it's just that
um you know instead of instead of makes
perfect sense
thanks for complaining yeah okay
so um oh actually i forgot to expand so
actually it's here so sorry
uh so the line was there i just forgot
to hit
hit page down um yeah so the the
the alpha is being strengthened the
whole time
okay um so
so again uh we have
this essentially it's a grounding right
so i'm doing this
grounding that is going one by one
and the
the strange thing about this grounding
is that i have an interpretations for
peace and f but
only in the points that i have
grounded so far so this is
probably answering a question in the
chat whether some this eye is like a
partial implication then yeah exactly
yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly and other
listeners are worrying about whether we
are in
inside epr still or outside
yeah yes i i yeah it's i
yeah it's essentially epr yeah i mean
it's i'm kind of
i'm kind of hesitant to say it's exactly
epr
because i have functions but
since it's since it's finite
model they're not real functions right
because they have a
finite range so i could rewrite
each function as a bunch of predicates
that would encode the value of the
function
if that answers the um from a complexity
point
yeah i mean it's you know it's obviously
not a directly a sat problem because
you have predicate certain functions but
there's no variables it's just constants
so um and i think the complexities of
the people asking approve of this answer
so yeah
yeah um i think we can continue
yeah no but i think danielle has uh has
has conceded i think he is he's agreeing
now
now we have a what 100 buy-in
um and i think the complexity of this is
is known to be the same
uh next time complete um
so yeah so so we get this partial
uh interpretation on the existing
ground terms but so we don't necessarily
know what's the part interpretation for
the whole
for the whole domain so imagine that
someone gives you a let's say a truth
table that is partially filled in
and you're trying to figure out what's
the rest so that that's not necessarily
is clear and obviously you have many
options
uh probably typically you know double
exponential
uh number of options how to do that
because the the grounding is will be
small because you need to keep it in
memory and you just construct it
construct it one by one
so this is i think this is a kind of a
more general problem that goes beyond
this finite model finding it also
appears in smt
so you know this is kind of why i got
interested in this problem because
it's it's a kind of a step between qbf
and smt but um essentially the the
these kind of issues remain everywhere
so
you know typically what happens in in
smt solvers
is they just assume some sort of a
default right so you
have you know that your function should
be
a return three if the argument is four
and should return
three if the argument is three and then
we don't know the rest so it's just put
some sort of default like zero
and then you might not be able to find
ever
the interpretation because you're just
looking at some
at some small portions of the truth
table
so rather than doing that i was
interested in
learning the rest right so again you
have a partially filled in truth table
or a multiplication table
and you're wondering whether you can
just
extrapolate to the rest so rather than
just
filling in a default everywhere you just
put
some some learned value so you look at
what you have so far and you try to
learn from that
so here is kind of an example where this
would work and essentially it's the same
thing
as this bit vector that i had in qbf
it's obviously syntactically not the
same thing but in some sense
a similar um idea so i'm i'm saying
there's some predicate with n variables
and i'm saying that the predicate should
be true if and only if
the first variable is equal to some
constant t
and of course i mean if i look at this i
know well this is actually a definition
this is not
even a problem i can get rid of it but
of course i can
hide this kind of semantics in something
that the
solver cannot detect
so if i ground all the x variables in
the argument as 0
and if i flip the first one to 1
and the rest to 0 i can learn from that
that that the predicate should
should be true if and only if t is
0 right so
so this is you know this is how how it
how it happens
so i say well p over all zeros
should be true if and only if t is zero
so this is
this is no there's no learning here i'm
just plugging in
the values of x's and here i'm plugging
the value
of of x's with one and all zeros and now
the right-hand side change but this is
just substitution there's no magic here
so we know that this should be true and
i do this partial interpretation of p
and well t i don't know let's say t is
one we don't know what it's it what it
should be it doesn't really matter for
us and um then i say well p
of all zero should be false and p one of
uh all zeroes uh should be true
so again so for pre for p i have just
two lines of the truth table defined
all zeros and one and all zeros
and i can i can learn from this because
oh actually this just depends on the
first variable
so i fill in the rest of the truth table
by just looking at the first variable
and in this case this will work right
um sorry um yeah okay
i should say something about the results
i didn't
put any results i i could have had um
so the the results were a little bit
ambivalent
um so i should probably admit to that so
i mean you know
this this expansion somehow was
typically beaten by
just expanding everything so i was
looking at some
benchmarks from tptp which is a library
of first order logic problems
and somehow like this very careful
expansion
going one by one just didn't pay off
like it
because typically you have these small
clauses with few variables
it just paid off to to expand everything
so
so in this finite model finding
using these finite domains um it
i'm sure you know there will be some
cases where this paid off but
it didn't pay off for me um however i
think
these ideas still translate to to
some other domains so i mean this is
something that i still
have as one of the one of the targets to
to have some some sort of learning like
this
for more complicated domains
um yeah any questions here
oh yeah there is um how can i get the
slides and list of the sighted
references
yeah i can i can upload that yeah um
just maybe jakub if i forget bother me
or
um i guess or
you like choose your favorite search
engine to google mikolaisyanota and use
email
yes you can yeah that's the worst cases
no but uh yes um yeah i don't know if
simon posts
slides on line i'm actually not sure
about that
i mean these slides are just reside
currently on my computer right so
unless i put them anywhere they won't be
anywhere
um okay okay make that as homework
yeah um okay so and uh yeah so as
as as jacob was advertising
in at the beginning so this part of the
talk
uh is going to be much shorter so um
this i'm getting to the final part and
this is
kind of work in progress but um
yeah so i i kind of i have this problem
that i
i always like to talk about the stuff
that i'm working on now
so you know some of it is is maybe a
little bit
half-baked but hopefully hopefully
interesting so
okay so like now we want to move
to to general smt so again we have some
some uh first order logic problem with
the theories
and one thing that we kind of rely on
in smt with regards to quantifiers
is this famous herb bronze theorem which
i'm sure many of you know if you don't
know it's it's not
it's not terribly complicated so
the intuition is that if i have
a quantified formula and
then it's unsatisfiable if and only if
i can ground it with terms
with finitely many terms and make it
unsatisfiable
yeah so um so to give an example so i
have
i have this formula that says that
f is an identity so fx always return
x so this is a quantified part of the
formula
and then i say well if i apply f
twice to to some constant c it should be
different from
c and now obviously this cannot be true
because f
always returns the same but of course
in order to prove that i need to know
what equality means
uh and what the quantifier means etc and
functions and
stuff like that but
i say that i can get rid of the
quantifiers by instantiating
the quantifier with finitely many terms
and in this particular case i plug in
c right so if i plug in c
into instead of x i get that f of c
is equal to c and then i plug in f of c
into x and i get f of f of c is equal to
fc
right so now i have the original ground
statement that was saying that
applying f twice to c is different from
c
and then i have two statements that i
derived from the universal quantifier
sometimes people refer to these as
lemmas
and they say well if you apply to
f to c i get exactly the same and if i
apply f
twice to c i get the same thing as
applying f to c but we already know that
applying f to c
is equal to c and this gives a
contradiction here right so
using using then uh some
some sort of equality reasoning i
already get a contradiction and i don't
have to worry about quantifiers
so this this looks kind of nice because
i'm saying
essentially the the take a take-home
message is
well i don't need to worry about
quantifiers as i
as long i know as i know what values
i should plug into the quantified
variables
and of course that's the that's the hard
part because i don't know
which which which values i should plug
in
uh but if i know then then
then things become easy in in
in in quotes at the high level what this
is saying is sort of
if if the formula isn't true then i can
always find the
finite counter example yeah
or is it saying more than that or a
little bit more than a
it's not really a counter example
because you're like you're you need to
plug in
um you need you might need to plug in
multiple
right so like for x i need to plug in
two different terms for x it's not not
exactly a counter example but
i can do a grounding maybe let's say
grounding i can i have a finite
grounding
that
and then okay in the context of
smt there is something that sometimes
people
refer to as like an improved herb brands
theorem
which is saying essentially the same
thing is that
i only need to look at the
terms that are in the formula
however the catch is that the formula is
growing so what do
what do i mean so imagine that you have
some quantified part of the formula and
some ground part
so the g has no quantifiers
and i look at the at the part that has
no quantifiers and i look for all the
ground terms that i have there
and i pick one and i plug it into x
right and i get um another ground part
of of the formula right so i get
this lemma right so i pick some term
from
from g and i add it to my ground part so
now my ground part is larger because i
instantiated the quantifier
now my pool of terms that i can pick to
plug in
into x is growing so it's a kind of an
onion structure
so initially i can only plug in things
that come from g
and in the second step i can pick
anything that comes from g
and the lemma that comes from
substituting
uh t1 into x and i continue
like this so you know i'm getting
these levels of terms so initially i
have only the terms in g
and then i have the terms that that come
from the substitutions
and i'm picking those
so in the end
the set of possible substitutions
is infinite because it keeps growing
but in each step i'm looking at a
finite number of terms so
algorithmically
this is nice right so so i'm not
i don't need to pick a term that just
comes out of the blue i'm just looking
at the terms that are
in the formula right now and
i don't need to worry about the rest and
it's it's
it's known to be complete yeah so this
is this
this improve her brand's theorem so this
this is nice i should say there is an
issue if i have theory so this works if
i have
no theory so just equality and functions
but i mean there is one small example so
i'm saying that
c is 21 and i'm saying that c has no no
factoring so i'm saying for whatever o
and p
i picked that and both are uh greater
than one that
then the multiple of o and p should be
different in c
and of course this is this whole thing
is unsatisfiable
because i if i plug in three and seven
into the
you know the quantifier it it just it
just says 21 is different from c
and c is different from c is equal to
21. so
this immediately uh immediately falls
however there is no three and seven in
the formula anywhere
right so um so it's not you know it's it
gets
it gets um it gets trickier
with with um theories
and plus there's issues with uh
induction
right so things that you need to prove
with induction
they're also somewhat out of reach
anyhow this is a hard problem so we we
know that
quantifiers in smt is hard so we we use
this
we just pretend that we have no theories
and so this gives us an algorithm uh
that really just does what i just
described so i have some ground part and
the quantified part
and i um
and i'm just i'm just
extending the ground part with with
terms that are coming from the ground
part
in every step you know while
g is satisfiable right so as long as g
is
satisfiable the moment it becomes
unsatisfiable i stop and i know the
formula is unsatisfiable
um in some strict sense i should not
call this
i should not call this an algorithm
because it's not guaranteed to stop
because it might i might never find
the right substitution to make it
unsatisfiable
in particle if it is if it's satisfiable
but this comes with the problem because
uh typically uh
things in smt are undecidable
okay so this is this was just a kind of
a taste of the theory
that is behind the quantifiers in
smt
and the so the take take away
message here is that i can just look at
the terms that are currently
in the formula and pick one of those
terms and plug in it
into into the quantifier and continue
however
this choice in is always going to be in
some sense non-deterministic so we're
asking the question can machine learning
help us with this task
right so if i have many terms that i can
pick to to plug in
which one uh should i choose and
and this is uh this is what i've been
working on
most uh recently so we
use we're using the the smt solver cvc4
which is one of the
one of the state-of-the-art smt solvers
um very nice to use open source
github and and everything and supports a
lot of
theories so so very amenable to this
kind of work
and i'm assuming that for each variables
uh each variable i have a bunch of terms
that i can plug in the depending
you know this might depend on the type
of the variable etc
and then i'm assuming that i have some
predictor
that lets me sort the terms
and then i'm instantiating the tuples
of these terms into the quantified
variables
so i'm being a little bit vague here um
so yeah so so i mean just just to recap
very quickly
um i have a i have a bunch of
quantifiers
and each instantiation means you know
substituting a tuple
of terms for for each variable i need to
pick one term
right and currently i'm kind of ignoring
that it's a tuple
i'm just looking for for one order of
of terms for e it would be also
interesting to look at the tuples but
we're not doing that right now
so what is the machine learning that i'm
using now
so we're just just using bag of words
which is probably one of the simplest
uh embedding of of formulas
while ignoring names of course because
we don't want to learn things that
depend on names
so for instance if i see the expression
y plus x plus 3
i just see oh this is this i have plus
sign
twice i have two variables and one
number
yeah so this is my feature so it's nice
feature vector
given a term it's a bit of a sparse
sparse feature vector but reasonable
and when i'm looking at the candidates
that may be substituted into the
variable
for the purpose of resolving the
quantified problem
i just look at the quantifier and the
term
i calculate the feature vectors and i
concatenate them together
and this gives me a feature vector for
the term
so okay i mean there's different ways of
of doing this obviously this is what
we're doing right now
and we're just applying
these boosted trees these there's this
implant this framework light gbm
uh for for um for doing the prediction
for the learning and uh prediction
so um this is nice because it's
it's fairly quick so i can run it from
the solver
and i ask just ask for each term
what is the prediction value and then i
sort the terms according the
prediction value
yeah i i know this might be a little bit
vague this part is not yet written up
which
we're in the process of writing it up i
don't know if there's any
questions with respect to this
uh so one thing uh that was not clear to
me is
how are you training the machine
learning model here
oh yeah so as i just you know i just
solve
one instance and i look at the coin
the instantiations that were useful
right so some so um if i go back to uh
sorry um so essentially assuming there's
just one quantifier in the formula
there's more but it doesn't matter so
the solver will try
many tuples to instantiate these
variables
right and some of these tuples
were useful to disprove the formula and
some of them were just not useful so i
just have a
one zero classification useful not
useful
okay yeah of course you could try to you
know come up with something more
uh more fine-grained but this is what
we're using now
and uh one thing that we're using
for that is that cvc4
now has some sort of a capability of
producing uh
a proof so you know
this is an engineering problem but you
need to worry about it of course is that
you know you the solver just instead
does many instantiations but only some
of them were really needed
to disprove it and we need to get this
information out of the solver so that
um that part um that part
you know fortunately cvc4 does for us
um otherwise we would have to somehow
hammer it out
thanks um yeah pashutan is
asking one potential is that your model
would only learn to mimic the solver's
behavior
yes no might not
learn a novel strategy well okay i mean
i think i think you know
the the short answer would be uh well
the
uh any any machine learning approach can
overfit
um um so that you know that
that would be probably the short answer
the longer answer is that you know the
features that we're using
are extremely
lossy just to say i mean there's a lot
of information lost right so
i'm just looking at the term and the
quantifier and i'm not looking at the
rest of the formula
and i'm just using it as a bag of words
so
the model really has very little
information
um about what is happening actually
this was one of the issues that we had
at the beginning i was using some
shorter
shorter feature vectors and i was just
getting too many
feature vectors that were exactly the
same
so that so we had to grow it um
yeah i mean but of course you're right
that
we have a bit of a chicken and egg
problem that
somehow um the training samples
are coming out of the solver and then
we're using it
in the solver i i will show some
experiments
um so so i think it's it's not the case
that um to a degree but to a degree it
probably is happening um
i'll maybe i'll just show very quickly
some some experiments that
might might
shed some light on this um
one thing is um yeah actually one thing
that i should say
with respect to this even if we
just improved the solver that it would
find
things faster i think that would be good
right so
so imagine that the solvers
the solver is going to instantiate these
all variables with zeros
and then with all ones and all twos and
whatever
until it's it finds that
plugging in all tens or all hundreds
was useful right so it went through
many of these unused unuseful ones like
all zeros all ones i don't know
but in the end i only needed this this
100 and if you know if i already
was able to to make the solver to come
up with this 100
faster than before it would still you
know it would still be interesting
because i'm making the solar faster
um yeah so um yeah it's a good question
i i think
it's uh it's non-trivial but i think
there is then
there's a lot of factors um in in
in the problem so
um yeah so some some sort of um
preliminary
results so um so this is some
class of problems that are coming from
the uf
uh lufflia
logic which means that i have functions
uninterpreted functions
and linear integer arithmetic
and in this setup we run the solver
and it solves some instances and we
learn
from those and we run the solver again
on the instances that we have not solved
yeah so this is uh this is kind of this
little bit this issue with that
paschutan is pointing to that we're
learning what to do from the solver
itself
however we do get some some some
improvement right so
there is a spike of number of
instances that the solver has solved at
the beginning and then you know then
it's
uh plato's um and and we're not we're
not
we don't seem to be able to push it um
push it further
um
yeah i think yeah i think there is uh
there's some more
comment from from paschutan yeah this
yeah i mean you could
you could definitely use some more
advanced uh
approaches i mean yeah um
okay uh so so you know so so this is
this is
it is showing something where we're um
we're getting something um
and this is a different scenario
so this is a kind of a funny experiment
um so i ran the
i ran the um different types of logics
so i
trained on a different logic and used it
on another one
so so i ran these benchmarks
sorry from uh oofnia which is
uninterpreted functions and nonlinear
arithmetic
so i learned a model on those problems
and then i ran this learned model as a
predictor
on different a different set of problems
where
there's no longer non-linear problems
but only in linear problems
um and actually it it it improved so
i mean this family has a lot of
let's say easy problems right so uh this
is 20 seconds so
um there's still there's nothing really
happening um until this 5000
uh last last thousand problems that we
can solve
and you can see um sorry i you can see
that
the the machine learning uh curve is
slightly slower so of course
so i'm calling the model so i'm not
learning anything i'm just
predicting and predicting prediction
still
cost me time right so even even though
it's these boosted trees they are fairly
fast
i still i still need to run them for
many
possible candidates and um
so that it's a little bit slower but not
horribly
and in the end it surpasses the number
of uh
solved instances so that was this was a
kind of a pleasant
um pleasant surprise for me that even if
i learn on a on a very different
set of problems i can learn from that
um and another thing that we were
uh looking into and this is also just
being
written up so so instead of using
bag of words we are looking into these
graph neural networks
and we're not using it for quantifiers
so this is a little bit
going outside of quantifiers but it's
still ml for logic
so the idea is that you know instead of
instead of having
back of words or whatever for or
whatever
hand designed features
we use these this modern
graph neural networks if you're not
familiar with it you know it's it's
roughly the idea is that i represent the
formula as a graph
but i ignore the names right so um
i just say you know there's a constant
there's a variable but i don't say
what's the name of the variable
and then i'm learning
a certain um they call it it's called
message passing but essentially
it's it's learning about some
coefficients
that that should be used how to um how
to aggregate
neighbors of each node and then there is
one node that
that all the other nodes joined in join
into and this
this gives me like kind of a result of
the of the network
um yeah i don't want to go into the
details but like it's a is this very
complex um
much more complex architecture
more expensive of course but the idea is
that
i don't need to come up with features
right so
rather than me as a designer coming up
with features somehow
the model figures out the features on
its own so this is roughly the
roughly the idea and hopefully it will
be smarter than me right
and we have used this this model for
this
portfolio prediction so for the the idea
is that you have a number of solvers
and somebody gives you a formula and you
should pick
which solver you should choose and
yeah we're getting some some fairly nice
nice results so you cannot get
better than the virtual best solver
which is essentially the same thing as
running all the solvers in parallel all
right so the
so this is there's no way how to surpass
the virtual best solver
using a portfolio uh but we're
getting fairly close right so the best
solver is somewhere here and the
the predictions are somewhere in between
um this is one family of problems
uh ophnia we also tried uh some
configurations of a single solver right
so the
you might not have a portfolio of
solvers but
the solver itself has a lot of
configurations again
you know this is the virtual best and
this is this is the prediction
uh we're particularly we're particularly
happy with with this graph so
uh this is again the virtual best solver
and this these are
our predictions and it's really tightly
uh tightly closed to the um
to the um to the virtual best so i mean
um so this is not about
quantification per se but it's somehow
showing that
the smart representations
based on graph neural networks or or
maybe on something else but
you you can get you can get some good
performance
better performance than than designing
the features
yourself okay um
yes so so this is um um
this is um the end um and
just to quickly summarize so
i was trying to convince you today that
we have found out that machine learning
can help us with finite domains so
quantifiers of finite domains
and what was
somewhat unusual is that we needed to
learn objects
not just the prediction right so you
cannot just get
3.7 out of the the machine learning
model
you just you need an actual object
and in terms of first order logic
we have this improved herb brand theorem
that lets us just pick some terms that
are currently available in the formula
which makes the problem
uh more manageable it's still
undecidable but
we can algorithmically it's more
manageable
and so we can we can train prediction on
this
in this on this finite set and um
it seems that it's doing something and
and the finite the final
comment that was that you know other
than
using these hand design features
you can also use this graph neural
networks in in formulas and it's
it's it might give you a better
performance
okay so that's all for me and
happy to take more questions if there
are any
thanks a lot nikolas so
i'm doing the official applause on
behalf of everybody
uh we certainly do have time for for
questions
although we did have a fair number of
them already but uh it's always nice to
have more
uh there's a question great talk thanks
for the gnn's case
you just get the embedding once at the
beginning
and use that to choose the solver from
the portfolio
no i mean you have to uh you have to
construct the graph
right so you have to um like the
embedding is
it's kind of mysterious so you know this
this goes
against this um
and one thing that i i a little bit
don't like about it is that i mean
is that it goes against this interpreter
and machine learning right so
you're it's it's just a way
how to get a set of features from a
graph
right so essentially you need to
need to take the formula construct the
graph
and and evaluate the network on the
graph and that that gives you the
features
um then that you learn and that you use
in in some standard settings
yeah you do yeah you have to always uh
you always have to recreate the graph
any other questions or comments before
we
let go mikolaj again just to put a
reminder in the chat that people who
can make it who are in a nice enough
time zone are warmly welcome to come
together town
at the to the simons institute at the
other town afterwards
but first while we have mykolash here we
can ask more questions if
there are any more questions
you use only abstractions under
approximation that you think to use
also over approximations
yeah i've i've been somehow thinking
about this at some point so i know that
this kind of work is
very popular in um
for instance with invariant loop
invariant generation
or invariant generation in software
verification so people do
under pro approximation and over
approximation
uh and i think i was thinking about it
at some point
and i was not able to conceptualize it
so
somehow it was not
making sense to me or i didn't i
couldn't make sense
out of it it definitely an interesting
question how is it possible that in some
country example guided approaches you
can do
under and over approximation and
here maybe not um
yeah i don't have a good answer it's
definitely
if someone has an answer to that it
would definitely be interesting
so this question might be a little bit
premature but is that do you think
there's any hope of
not only getting improvements from ml
but
sort of being able to interpret why ml
is doing what it's doing and gain an
understanding rather than just the black
box magic improvements
yeah i mean so yeah it's it's uh
yeah the whole field um yeah it's kind
of it seems to me that it's
you know people are trying to have
explainable ai
but explainable ml but
then the best the best approaches are
less and less explainable um
in some sense like um in some sense what
i'm doing
is um you know is maybe not
not so strange right because um
maybe so so the solver deals with
formulas that are written by humans and
humans don't write arbitrary formulas
but they write some
formulas that come from some some
problems and
from some real world um
inspiration so it it's possible maybe
that statistically i can
i can learn somehow what people are
writing
in some sense right so um so it's not
it's not uh it's not such a
not such uh black magic but but in the
end
yeah i agree it's um
it's um it's it's a little bit uh
it's difficult i mean it but because
all the simpler models so we also i
started we or we started with some
simpler
prediction models and that was
it was just not getting too too much
um too much improvement not not really
anything so
so like these so you have some very nice
interpretable simple models
linear models or
logistic regression or or decision trees
so these things are fairly
easy to interpret but they're
they have such a small prediction power
um
that in the end they're hard to use
again we've had the simon's institute
gather town link in the chat now
several times so that you you'll be able
to find it uh
people who can are warmly welcome to
come there
any final questions for for mikolaj
before we
wrap up and thank michael again for a
great uh
presentation okay thank you for having
me
um yeah so hope to see you
all soon at some also non-non-virtual
event
okay thank you so much bye